qu'olivier py ton avocat au barreau de
washington or les piétons merci d'être
avec nous alors des propos du dr fauci
pas vraiment rassurant l'épidémie qui
n'est pas contrôlée des chiffres qui
pourraient encore augmenter davantage
quel est l'état d'esprit des américains
est ce qu'il ya une forme de panique aux
etats-unis non les endroits les plus
touchés
ça commence effectivement on a une
reprise de la pandémie par le sud et par
l'ouest c'est-à-dire des états qui
dézone qui jusqu'à présent n'avaient pas
été touchés par le virus
et qui donc aujourd'hui d'une certaine
manière rattrape le reste du pays
en revanche dans le nord-est par exemple
on a une on a une baisse sensible du
nombre de de contamination ce qui fait
que la réaction des gouverneurs qui sont
en première ligne dans chacun des états
pour lutter contre la pandémie pour
prendre les mesures contre la pandémie
est en fait assez disparate c'est à dire
que dans les états du sud très touchés
comme en floride au texas en arizona en
particulier on a recommencé art confiner
les restaurants sont fermés les bars ont
fermé un certain nombre de lieux clos
sont fermés alors que dans d'autres
zones on continue à des confits des
comme par exemple autour de washington
donc tout dépend comme c'est un pays
fédéral bien entendu tout dépend un
petit peu de la gravité de la pandémie
localement et des décisions qui sont
prises par les gouverneurs est-ce qu'il
est exact de dire que les états où ça se
gâte un qui se dégrade
ce sont des états d'émerger par des
gouverneurs républicains
oui mais en fait je je ne jouerai pas
cette carte-là parce que par exemple la
californie reprend aussi la californie
est aux mains des démocrates
c'est plus géographique alors on peut
faire évidemment un lien entre le fait
que les républicains soient beaucoup
plus représenté dans le centre du pays
et dans le sud est donc c'est
effectivement les zones qui pour
l'instant sont touchés mais de là à dire
que c'est de la faute des gouverneurs
républicains c'est un peu compliqué une
chose est sûre un tsonga pardonnez moi
je manque ou parce que je n'ai pas dit
ça mais c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on
peut lire ici ou là et c'est vrai qu'un
une différence de doctrine on le voit
donald trump qui ne porte pas de masque
d'ailleurs c'est un débat dans le pays
on hésite à confiner donc ça peut-être
des conséquences tout de même d'être
républicain ou démocrate dans ce cas
précis de gestion de la crise alors là
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est à
dire qu'il ya une politisation du virus
entre les républicains qui décident
d'une part de nier la gravité de la
pandémie et deuxièmement voire même de
demander d'exiger le déconfinement et
les démocrates qui sont dans une logique
de respect et de soutien des directives
sanitaires qui sont prises et il est
vrai que parmi les états qui sont
actuellement les plus touchés en tout
cas les grands états je pense à la
géorgie qui a été le premier état des
confiner la floride et le texas
il y a une responsabilité des
gouverneurs en l'occurrence républicain
qui effectivement sans doute des conf il
est beaucoup trop tôt
alors vous qui êtes à washington comment
cela se passe passe quand on parle
beaucoup effectivement du manque de
civisme de certains
d'autres au contraire qui applique
strictement les règles comment ça se
passe notamment capitale fédérale
washington et les états qui sont autour
respecte énormément les consignes
sanitaires c'est à dire les gestes
barrière la distanciation sociale en
plus washington fait partie dans la
région la ville
le district de columbia fait partie des
seuls endroits où la houle a le nombre
de contaminés continuer à baisser alors
que par exemple en pennsylvanie l'art
commencent à remonter et dans le dos
were on est également une reprise ainsi
qu'en virginie occidentale donc on est
un petit peu un îlot entouré de d'état
ou ça a tendance à reprendre ici les
gens font vraiment attention quand on
leur dit porter des masques ils portent
des masques quand on leur dit de garder
une distance
il l'a gardée donc ça se passe plutôt
bien alors on est à quatre mois de la
présidentielle américaine évidemment ça
pèse lourdement on imagine sur cette
campagne le disait lui-même joe biden
qui me frappe à deux meetings avant
cette présidentielle c'est un pari
risqué selon vous pour le candidat
démocrate non je ne crois pas je joe
biden joue vraiment la carte de du
respect absolu des règles c'est à dire
que il a rendu hommage au docteur
anthony fauci hier en disant que si
jamais il était élu président il le
garderai donc le fameux chef de la task
force coronavirus de la maison blanche
que vous avez cités tout à l'heure dans
votre reportage il est dans une logique
de respect total est donc dans la
logique de cette de ce respect est bien
il a décidé d'ajourner les d'annuler les
les manifestations les meetings qu'il
avait prévu c'est à dire que les grands
moments de la campagne qui va se
dérouler c'est d'une part la convention
démocrate et d'autre part évidemment les
trois débats qui sont prévues avec
donald trump d'ici au 3 novembre
est-ce qu à l inverse le rebond
l'épidémie fragilise encore davantage
donald trump qui a vécu cette séquence
compliqué aussi avec les manifestations
contre les violences préfère écouter
absolument parce que donald trump a fait
un pari c'est celui de la relance de la
delà de la machine économique américaine
le plus rapidement possible pour
retrouver les standards qui étaient ceux
de l'économie us au début de l'année
avant l'attendait vie or la deuxième
vague parce que l'on peut véritablement
parler de deuxième vague contrarie
complètement ses plans en l'occurrence
il ne trouve pas la réponse adéquate
celle qui rassure en particulier son
électorat c'est à dire les seniors les
plus de 60 50 70 ans qui sont évidemment
ceux qui sont les plus menacés par le
par le corona virus donc il a un vrai
problème politique qui peut si le choral
un virus poursuit vi posé énormément de
problèmes pour le mois de novembre
c'est son électorat qui est touché ce
sont les zones dans lesquelles il est
fort où les républicains sont forts qui
sont des zones où heath qui sont touchés
et donc il est effectivement
actuellement sans réponse véritable pour
se rassurer son électorat d'avoir été
avec moi
sur rt france